cinéma d autres d'art dramatique eh bien
mon avis il ya une chose qui différencie
le sud maintenant de tous les autres
sont des spectacles toutes les pentes de
prétexte à quitter jusqu'à maintenant et
c'est le groupe le gros plan d'aidé sur
les trois une ère sous sol absolument
mystérieuse je suis explique pas en tout
cas c'est quelque chose qu'on l'avait
jamais jusqu alors peut-être peut-être
sait-il chose traitement analogue dans
l'opéra c'est le seul os lorsqu'une
fille
lorsqu'un contralto lançons l'enterrent
brusquement tout le décor disparaît
brusquement tous les
les comparses tous les autres acteurs
les costumes tout ça disparaît et toute
une salle est suspendu aux mouvements de
lèvres d'une fille et on suit les
modulations de la gorge et bien le gros
plan sésame en beaucoup plus fort le
gros plan c'est c'est le meilleur pause
je crois qu'il ait jamais existé dans
toute l'histoire du spectacle s'est
brusquement un bien mystérieux et très
fort entre ce personnage et sur les
grands et les gens dans la salle des
gens dans la salle
brusquement ce tout à fait doubler
eux-mêmes ils pénètrent dans ses acteurs
et actrices qui est sur un écran ils
s'identifient à lui ou à elle et je
crois que ça le grand mystère du cinéma
je crois que c'est ça qui appelle ses
deux mains
je crois que c'est pour ça que des
milliers de gens aiment le cinéma
ces deux temps en temps pour s'oublier
eux mêmes dans l'émotion du à la
contemplation d'un robot alors d'après
vous ce serait le groupe lo qui
donnerait aux comédiens tout son pouvoir
je le crois ça ne veut pas dire que dans
un film du plan lointaine soit pas
extrêmement nécessaire peut-être même le
gros plans n'existerait pas si elle veut
pas eu des plans loin des avants mais
c'est au moment de gros plan que l'on
arrive à établir ce pot et plus vivement
qu'on avait jamais sur 3 3
par conséquent la valeur du comédien et
d'amande ou d'après vous une valeur une
pratique absolument
c'est un phénomène qui bloque il ne
s'agit pas tellement remarquez quand un
grand acteur d'écran un acteur puissant
dans les gros plans peut également être
un très bon comédien
ça peut arriver mais ça n'a pas
tellement d'importance des des
personnalités de l'écran qui ont conquis
les foules
si vraiment les ont absorbés par leur
gros plan quelques points n'ont pas eu
tellement de talent mais il avait ça
c'est très mystérieux ne se quittent pas
je crois qu'il faut que le créateur
souhaite absolument inconscient et s'il
est inconscient il est évidemment
modeste
remarquez ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
sera pas profondément tort que yeux et
pour rivaliser dans la vie il arrivera
peut-être pour faire son gros blanc si
ses lecteurs ou bien pour diriger 500
âmes et trentels il arrivera peut-être
l'un en ce bilan je suis le plus grand
homme du monde sait ça n'a aucune
importance ce soit du tout petits
défauts oublions les mais au moment de
la création il sous qu'il s'oublie
qu'une fois qu'ils ne se croient pas
subjectif il ne croit pas faire acte de
subjectivisme il faut que son action
soit avant tout objective
écoutez la halle est le meilleur exemple
c'est chez les peintres un peindre veut
faire un portrait de représenter quelque
chose vous présentez un arbre quel que
soit l'école de ce peintre
il s'agit de copier cet arbre a
doublement suivant des principes presque
pornographiques ou qu'il s'agisse de
tableaux abstraits tsan aucune
importance et se peindre 10 - c'est très
simple je me bats pas je pas parce que
j'ai devant les yeux
je me sens moi-même d'espacé jeu sur le
sur la toile je mets toute mon âme tout
mon corps je vais moi même je fais donc
de moi même au public et bien en réalité
plutôt dorian but et on le voit pas du
tout et on ne voit rien pour les autres
on ne voit rien sur la toile
au contraire pendant le père cézanne
n'emprunte pas dans une pomme mais
quelques poèmes était un an à part une
pomme et pendant un an peine est issu
est il transpirait il était malheureux
pour essayer de saisir toutes les
caractéristiques de cette pomme
même les caractéristiques intérieures et
aident pas ils s'identifiaient à cette
famille noble et finalement sur l'écran
ce que l'on avait sauté
évidemment cette pub mais ces peuples
étaient plus ce format de chez elle que
s'il avait plateforme
[Musique]